I know NAFTA was a good idea it's
created millions of jobs and it has
helped the economies of all three of
these nations I have to do is go to
Detroit and see the thousands of trucks
lined up every day or go to our southern
border there have been winners and
losers and that's the problem but free
trade is something I think that's vital
the future of America as a free trader I
will open up every market in the world
to Iowa agricultural products people
lost jobs yes they have and they're
going to lose jobs although the overall
gain in jobs has been pretty impressive
but we can't leave anybody behind we
cannot leave people behind because of
being displaced workers and I am
committed to implementing training and
education programs that works through
our community colleges which are very
strong in Iowa and Taylor and implement
training and education programs for the
local needs so that we can have people
fill jobs and not be left behind at a
very early stage of their life including
of their life including if necessary
someone who had a high paying job that's
required to take a much lower paying job
to have a 4:11 sation so that they
wouldn't experience that dramatic change
in the